113 questions about evolution
with john perry evolutionary question
number 17
how do new blood vessels evolve welcome
ladies and gentlemen to the stated
casually youtube channel john perry here
make sure you subscribe to this channel
if you're not yet subscribed
yeah if you like to learn about
evolution that is if not then
you know whatever go do something else
today we're going to talk about
how blood vessels new blood vessels
evolve
and this question is kind of near and
dear to my heart because when i was a
little kid
you know i was raised in a religious
family and the religion that i belonged
to most people weren't
you know young earth creationists they
were you know a lot of people were fine
with
the theory of evolution but i had a
sunday school teacher when i was really
young
i was probably five years old and she
was a young earth creationist
and she would spend her time she was
actually the substitute
sunday school teacher and when whenever
she got a chance to substitute she'd get
on her
anti-evolution soap box and i was five
and so i just you know she was an adult
so i just believed everything she told
me one of the arguments against
evolution that she made is
blood vessels she said let's say that
there's a mutation that gives an animal
longer legs
well you need blood vessels to supply
those longer legs because the legs are
longer they need more blood vessels and
our blood vessels are extremely complex
and it is true
that our blood vessels are extremely
complex she told us that
you know if you were to stretch your
blood vessels end to end
they're so complex some of them are so
small but also long
that it would stretch thousands of miles
i think she said it would stretch it
all around the circumference of the
earth i'm not sure if that's true but
it's definitely true that our blood
vessel system is extremely long i mean
if you were to
you know pull out blood vessels if that
was your thing
and lay them end to end it would be it
i'm
i would not be surprised to learn that
it's it would be thousands of miles
so what she said is that if a mutation
makes your legs longer
you have to have hundreds of other
mutations that will design
the new vascular structures
that would supply those extra long legs
with the appropriate amount of blood so
that you can get oxygen to your cells
and so on
and this you know i was like a
five-year-old i didn't really understand
most of this
cellular biology stuff anyways because i
never learned it but i just
what she said stuck with me sorry my
dog's freaking out over here
okay manilow's gonna be in the video so
he was uh
he was having a fit over there hi buddy
so she's telling me
what she said stuck with me for quite a
while when i was learning about
evolution for the first time i started
learning about it on
david attenborough video actually and
then reading about it in the
encyclopedia when no one was around
because i thought i would get in trouble
uh this thing about blood vessels really
stuck with me
so okay allah wants to go
several years went by i never found an
answer to this blood vessel question
several years went by
and a friend of our families came by
and he was telling us that we need to
clip our dog's toenails
because if they get too long blood
vessels will start to grow
into the tips of the toenails so that
when you do clip them
eventually they'll actually bleed
and i thought what blood vessels
don't have to evolve with thousands of
mutations
in order to fill a new space if tissue
grows
blood vessels will grow to fill and
supply that tissue
so wait a minute my sunday school
teacher was
wrong eventually i grew up and i you
know
learned how to use the internet and i
was able to learn about this process
called
angiogenesis so angiogenesis is
how new blood vessels form it's the
process
now there's actually a different process
for the the formation of the very first
blood vessel structures in an embryo
but this is how after those first little
vessel
buds form in an embryo this is how they
form after that
when oxygen starved tissue develops so
the fetus is growing and there are cells
that have developed
that are not getting enough oxygen they
start to secrete a molecule called
vegf vascular endothelial growth factor
so endothelial cells are these cells
that make up a blood vessel so
all the cells here that are pink those
are the blood vessel cells the blue ones
here
are you know like the tissue cells and
then the the pink ones are the
endothelial cells and these cells are
really neat
they form the wall of a blood vessel
well they line the wall of a blood
vessel they actually excrete
stuff outside of their cells to form
kind of a sheath around them as well so
you have these cells and then you have a
sheath that they actually form on the
outside of
the of the vessel which isn't really
shown here but as
an embryo is forming certain cells will
start to not
be able to get enough oxygen because
there's not enough blood flow to them
and when that happens these cells will
start excreting
this protein right here this diagram
shows you the
protein backbone if you're used to
looking at these types of diagrams you
can tell this is a really small protein
it's a very small protein that's
excreted from the cells and it acts as a
signal
so it just the cells produce a bunch of
it and it starts just dissipating around
the cell in
every direction every possible direction
now these cells
they exist in these really convoluted
mazes of other cells and other
collagen fibers and so on but the genius
of this system is
these little proteins they're small
enough that they can just bounce around
between cells
and they just dissipate in the fluid
that exists
until they hit a blood vessel and when
they hit a blood vessel
the cells inside that blood vessel so if
we go back to the the
picture of the cells here those cells
when they get hit by this protein
they put out a branch and they start
growing towards
the you can think of it as like they're
growing towards the scent
of the cell that's that's starving that
needs oxygen
they follow these little proteins as if
they were smells
like a hound tracking a uh a rabbit
this is so brilliant i say brilliant but
it's actually it's it's stupid
you have this system these cells are
just excreting molecules in every which
way
into this convoluted maze that is the
body tissue of this
growing organism and
the by just bouncing around having lots
of these little proteins just bouncing
around every which way
the ones that end up hitting the blood
vessel first
are the ones that happen to have bounced
down
the shortest possible pathway towards
the blood vessel
so the blood vessel just by following
that scent as it grows towards
the oxygen starved tissue it will just
by default just
as its mere consequence of entropy it
will be following the shortest possible
route
to that oxygen starved tissue and as it
gets closer to that oxygen starved
tissue it's going to be bringing blood
with it which will be bringing oxygen
and so
this the body tissue will actually start
to get enough oxygen
and when when it gets sufficient oxygen
it's going to stop secreting these
vague f molecules and what's going to
happen is that you know
different vessels surrounding this will
have grown together and met in the
middle and
blood will start passing through and
this tissue will now have access to all
the oxygen that it needed
this is absolutely beautiful it's just
really stupid interactions i'm panicking
and sending out a molecule in every
which direction
and then another another structure
that's like i will grow towards this
signal
these two mindless actions end up
solving what in computer science we call
the the traveling salesman
problem if you got a salesman that has
to visit multiple cities
during the day in his route to sell
people's stuff what is the shortest
possible route
to hit all the cities that are needed to
be hit and then get back home at the end
of the night
and blood vessels solve this equation
it's a really complicated equation
just by these two stupid behaviors by
oxygen starved tissues sending out
signals in any which way
and blood vessels growing to where those
signals are coming from
it's awesome the answer to our question
how is it that new blood vessels evolve
actually they don't this system
emerged very early on in our
evolutionary history
and it allows blood vessels to
infiltrate any new tissue that ends up
evolving so
if i have a mutation that makes me grow
extra long legs it's not a problem
the blood vessels will just
automatically
go towards that oxygen starved tissue
as i'm developing as a fetus and supply
that oxygen starved tissue
with the appropriate amount of oxygen
now this does kind of force us to ask
the question
well how did the first you know vessel
growth
signaling pathway evolve and that is a
question that i will address
some other day next question